Dennis is seconds away from what is the
biggest win of his career but watch out
there is a Checkmate in one how do you
fight it do you push the Jeep Pawn do
you slide up with your king he does it
he is fighting it but he still needs to
be careful Magnus is not going to let
this be easy there's so many checks
against that black king there are no
Pawns in front of it and here comes
another mating net the queen can slide
back to H7 at any moment but he's ready
to take this Pawn on E6 Perfect Defense
from Dennis
wow amazing def look how he's organized
himself The Black Queen now defending
the king the black Rook on a nice safe
Square the Black Knight is defended as
well Magnus swearing Magnus cursing his
luck here he knows Dennis has done
perfectly and he's about to lose with
white Magnus this nearly never happens
the pawn drops Magnus resigns Dennis
takes a historic Victory did you feel
like you missed some chance at the end
there were you just what happened there
no it was just frustrating